i have for you today
some this is probably my favorite video
from the last three months
other than my own interview with mike
pillow mike lindell the ceo of my pillow
this is a fantastic interview
from australia
where sarah ferguson interviews
sydney powell
now sydney powell was one of the lawyers
going around the country
trying to legislate trump's voter fraud
claims at different points in time
sydney powell was at one point in the
oval office meeting with trump
at another point denounced or not not
denounced but uh uh
disassociated from trump claiming this
is not someone working for me this is
someone doing her own thing
this interview
is like nothing i have ever seen at one
point sydney powell just cuts the
interview let's take a look at some of
the highlights listen to this and the
what's the point here
the point i know some people say david
don't tell us what the point is let us
watch it
look at how when we go full circle these
people who were adamant about their
claims
when they were carrying out these legal
challenges
now you can tell they never knew what
the hell they were talking about let's
take a listen look at this
let's get a few simple facts straight in
how many states were smartmatic machines
and software used in the 2020 election i
don't even know the exact numbers but
you were making some um big statements
very dramatic critical statements about
smartmatic you must have known what
their involvement was in the election no
you'd have to go look at our complaint
against with
with respect to the four states that we
filed legal complaints in to get the
details of that a google search would
have shown you that smartmatic was
operating in one single county in
california
well i'm saying i think their
involvement's probably a lot bigger than
that okay so now you start to see
sydney powell doesn't even really know
the involvement of smartmatic which was
like the centerpiece of her claims
and without evidence even after being
told the facts about smartmatics she
just says i just believe they were more
involved oh okay and is is that the type
of argument you would expect to make in
court sydney research or fact checking
did you do at the time to find out what
smartmatic's actual involvement in the
election was if you work for smartmatic
[Laughter]
you've made an allegation against
smartmatic
that they stole no i'm a journalist i'm
wondering whether you have any basis for
the claims you make presidential
election i think it's incumbent on both
of us to know what smartmatics
involvement was it seems like a pretty
foundational fact i mean i'm confused
right now about why you're here because
you made how did you get into my house
ma'am who let you in series of
very strong allegations against
smartmatic and against dominion
containing many errors of fact do you
accept the fact now that the company
that you accused of stealing a national
election only operated in one county in
la in california no one county one state
no i'm not prepared to accept that fact
i think smartmatic's involvement was far
more significant than that do i think
they're trying to minimize their
involvement of course i do you said that
smartmatic owns
dominion how do you justify such a basic
factual error
i'm going to stop this interview right
it's wholly inappropriate in the
litigation that we're in but we're not
even in the area of great dispute these
are the simple facts of who owns what no
we're done
all right
so she gets these facts when we are in
litigation against me personally
i i understand that but
yes i understand that these are very
serious allegations
but these are also so
as you can tell
absolutely no factual basis for anything
she does eventually come back although
it seems almost like under protest let's
take a look at a little more
after some discussion ms powell agreed
to answer more questions yeah i'm highly
skeptical of how long this is going to
last
claiming her legal issues prevented her
from talking about the voting machine
companies
all of the organizations who had the
responsibility to
check the nature of this election and to
verify its results say there was no
fraud that's the propaganda they're
putting out i disagree with that
completely and we have and will produce
additional evidence that shows otherwise
how many years will it take to produce
the evidence they claim is coming i mean
i'm not asking it sarcastically i would
i would love to know from them do you
think we will get this in 22 2023 20
when will we get that evidence trump
says very soon very very soon um what
you're describing is a massive
country-wide fraud involving the fbi the
doj
the department of homeland security the
organizations who certify elections and
on and on all the way up to the attorney
general and thousands of local election
officials are you saying that thousands
of americans participated
in a fraud
i am saying that thousands of americans
had some role in it knowingly or
unknowingly it was essentially a
bloodless coup
where they took over the presidency of
the united states without a single shot
being fired who's they in that sentence
i i don't know who all that they are
they did it
i don't know who they are
they didn't even know they were doing it
but they did it
i would really like to know the answer
to that but it's a significant number of
they
and they knew exactly what they were
doing and they planned it for at least
three years this was no accident
do you ever hear yourself and think that
it sounds ridiculous
i know i know myself very well i've been
in me a long time
she has been inside of herself long
enough to know
she sounds totally normal my friends so
you know
is sydney powell delusional
is there a mental illness component here
is she just wrong
is there a financial incentive i don't i
don't think there is a financial
incentive i i ask that but i i'm pretty
sure the answer there is no
what on earth is going on with this
woman and that is just a stunning
stunning video we'll have more uh of
those clips
on the show's instagram you can find us
on instagram at davidpakmanshow and
while you're there
follow me at david.pakman
one of the best ways that you can
support what we do at the david pakman
show is supporting some of our awesome
sponsors today one of those awesome
sponsors is sheath underwear
a lot of us know all too well about the
sticking and the rubbing and the chafing
with traditional underwear especially
this time of year as the weather is
getting warm
sheath underwear have created unique
boxer briefs with multiple ergonomic
compartments in the front preventing
skin on skin contact everything stays
separate comfortable dry and cool
no more sweatiness no more chafing no
more readjusting it's a lifesaver sheath
underwear is giving the david pakman
show audience 20 off when you go to
sheath underwear dot com slash pacman
and use the promo code pacman give
sheath underwear a shot i've had a great
experience i believe you will too you
can find the link underneath this video
and don't forget to use promo code
pacman for 20 off